yeah because you should talk about this
all right so after months and years
of speculation and news and casting
rumors and casting facts uh we finally
have a trailer to Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and it starts out here William
Fichtner the white dude who plays
shredder he's like the city's gone to
nobody's happy Christmas is gone
the world needs heroes that's what your
father and I were trying to do miss
O'Neal swaro
all right here first of all I understand
how this is going to be and understand
how it looks I understand I'm once again
gonna be one of those entitled
standing behind a camera raging out
about a trailer in a movie like the
world owes him something and all that
I'm happy I get it I get what I'm
doing but I talk about movies that's
what I do here so when I see a trailer
and it makes me go I'm going to get on
camera and do my thing because my thing
is this that just makes me roll my eyes
when movies do this they're like oh we
can't actually have April O'Neil be what
April O'Neil has been for a long time
someone who came across the Turtles you
know our eyes a movie like this will
always have that character that they get
introduced into the situation and then
they see the characters for the first
time so you see the characters for the
first time we have a person to go along
the journey with us that's April O'Neil
I guess her dad was working with
shredder to create Turtles again it's
speculation maybe shredder wasn't
talking about the Ninja Turtles babies
talking about his military foot planets
in the movie yeah military foot clade
you see the Foot Clan they'll have guns
I'm like alert not ninjas now which I
give them points for consistency on that
I mean they turned shredder white he's a
white guy he's william fichtner loved
the actor not really shredder they
wanted to be inconsistent they could
have kept the Foot Clan ninja thieves
while shredders not Japanese but now
they were like we westernized shredder
we might as well westernized the Foot
Clan to give him guns and jet so if
you're gonna on something on
it all consistently so hey props credit
where credit's due I was thinking about
this why can I roll with the fact that
Bane is a white dude but he wasn't in
the comic books but he is in the movie
but I can't roll with this for Ninja
Turtles I want shredder to be Japanese
the reason is is because of the whole
culture behind it and I grew up with
Ninja Turtles the Foot Clan they were
abandoned ninja thieves that ruined
Japan then they went away and they were
in America and you're like who's doing
that so Ruka Saki is his immigrant from
Japan and they're operating on the DL
and they're taking the kids away it was
just it was a really cool culture and it
was all ninjas across the board the
turtles were ninjas Foot Clan were
ninjas shredder was a ninja splinter was
everyone
was a ninja now it was just military
you're like alright
the shredder outfit looks cool you see
it you're like alright that doesn't look
bad that I feel looks badass
but I'm just saying the entire essence
of what shredder was and what he brought
to America and that whole thing's not in
the movie so that makes me just go well
that's cool-looking armor shredder nah
but the trailer isn't all that it has a
couple of oh my god you I'm not
gonna let every dude I just you think
it's gonna be one of those things where
you're like maybe when I see it in
action I won't hate it so much and you
see her you're like no why you why Megan
Fox's April O'Neil why is William
Fichtner shredder why are the Foot Clan
just a bunch of military guys with guns
and grenades why did it all have to be
different when you have source material
why not just pull from that no
uphold from the source material took
liberties where liberties were due but
you pulled from the source material why
not just why not just do that this is
the part where I was like alright that
reminded me of Ninja Turtles that
doesn't irritate me so when Michelangelo
pops up behind what's-her-nuts and he's
like woo don't freak out cuz he's
clearly just a big turtle eesof oh don't
worry it's a mask see he pulls it off
he's like right and then she passes out
I'm like that reminds me of something
Michelangelo would do another point
credit where credit's due fact is this
movies directed by the guy who directed
this schlock oh look at the director of
first and foremost and ultimately that
makes me go see yeah well that was our
Ninja Turtle shot for this generation I
hope we enjoyed it it's gone now alright
so the trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
yeah you see that that was a gunshot not
as cool as hand-to-hand combat is it
that's why turning the Foot Clan into
military guys is